I want you to look me in the eye and
tell me that I don't belong here I want
you to look me in the eye and tell me
that my brother a dental student at UNC
his bride you said of six weeks also
about to join him at UNC dental and her
younger sister who is visiting them for
the afternoon were worthy of those
bullets because of their faith
when Trump says comments to the effect
that Muslims are worthy of being killed
with bullets dipped in pig's blood then
what you are essentially doing is is
saying that an entire group of people
are worthy of violence he's not
realizing that those same words that are
getting him points in the campaign are
also ones that are leading to
potentially lethal outcomes like they
have in the in the case of my family how
am I supposed to feel I mean my baby
brother was murdered a year ago eight
bullets was married six weeks prior -
you said two bullets one in the hip and
mobilizing her and one in the back of
her head lacerating her midbrain you're
a DA top see reports and one single shot
into the back of her son's head why how
is this acceptable these are three
American citizens Muslim American
University students who were murdered in
their home because of their faith this
is the acceptable racism of our time
what I expect from our leaders is one
who will uphold our rights our
constitutionally given rights I expect
to be treated as human
I expect to be treated like everyone
else and to be valued like everyone else